saluti fuori rotta oggi giocheremo
nuovamente sa di dover a chi ha
ricordato abbiamo già fatto due episodi
di indovina chi pauroso se non l'avete
vista andate a vederli dopo questo video
questa volta abbiamo aggiunto
nuovi personaggi horror anche voi potete
provare a indovinare il personaggio
mentre noi giochiamo e vediamo se
riuscite a indovinarlo magari prima di
noi infatti dovremo scegliere il
personaggio e l'altro dovrà fare delle
domande per indovinare quale di questi
personaggi horror e e ovviamente chi
indovina prima di una volta a testa
dovremo fare delle domande a cui si può
rispondere solo sì o no in ogni turno
quindi abbasseremo le case ad esempio il
personaggio è il naso sì se la risposta
è sì a il naso allora sicuramente
dobbiamo abbassare voldemort anche
berlino sta facendo da arbitro alla
nostra challenger anche aspettare però e
berlino poi dovrei scegliere il
vincitore ok che questo video raggiunge
i 10 mila mi piace giocheremo un'altra
volta indovina chi ora anzi consegnateci
quali altri personaggi volete che di un
gioco al gioco air iscrivete in
tantissimi come aveva fatto dove lo
avete comprato questa indovina chi
horror ma sono in realtà era un
indovinati normale e poi abbiamo
incollato i personaggi cattivi sopra
emesso i nomi sotto ma ora prendete i
pop corn mettetevi comodi e che la sala
interna iniziò allora hai scelto il tuo
personaggio
ho scelto il mio personaggio non è già
sesso
scegliendo sono indecisa tra due
personaggi sono due personaggi che a voi
piacciono tantissimo
ok ho scelto ho scelto il personaggio
iniziamo subito con le domande ma chi
inizia a fare le domande lo show di
berlino berlino chi comincia per league
e là dietro che sta provando a salire
marino partecipa alla challenge e allora
berlino ha detto che comincia vitale era
è giusta eh sì perché berlino sottomette
e va bene lidia vitale dai qual è la tua
prima domanda quando facciamo di
maremoto
0 il tuo personaggio ai capelli e
ai capelli
allora mister mettono nei capelli quindi
lo eliminiamo slider meno neanche a
preti freddino mai capelli e neanche
baldi neanche volte ma direi neanche il
gelataio e milan non so forse ce li ha
nascosti dietro gli orari eliminerei lo
slimer il grinch beh si sa il soggetto
quindi lo lascerei più ho fatto un sacco
di progresso con questa domanda
novità né in super vantaggio devo
assolutamente fare una domanda che
eliminerà tantissimi personaggi sta
sorridendo
loro terzo ride intorno a questo
personaggio e ma ci sono pochi i
personaggi che sorridono un altro punto
dai quali no non sta sorridendo lui sta
sorridendo sorriso no non fa sorridendo
mi dicevo eliminare tutti quelli che
sorridono di arrivati da eliminare
gelataio da eliminare liner da eliminare
gli stilisti da eliminare i crash da
eliminare di pietro c'è che sorride
tiffany non capisco se il lupo sta
sorridendo no ma penso di no quindi vi
ho eliminato un po ma vitale niente di
più
mi sa che ne eliminati di più tu con la
tua domanda è il tuo personaggio e
biondo no non è bionde mio personaggio
non è biondo quindi dobbiamo eliminare
tutti i biondi quindi la moglie di
chucky kiss cani poi all'appello no una
bella non è bionda
c'è altro di biondo o no solo eliminato
di farina
siamo pari allora la mia domanda è il
tuo personaggio a il rossetto
[Musica]
si sa il rossetto il mio personaggio
allora devo eliminare tutti quelli se
07 voldemort ha detto no si capisce
capisco che possa portarlo aspetto del
sud o
puramente renderman non è il rossetto
loro hanno tutti il rossetto anche fasi
di sopra che abbia rossetto giornate di
milano non si capisce se al rossetto ma
penso di no perché tutto è nero anche
sabato non è un aspetto no credi non era
neanche lo nego il super montaggio già
dracula a il rossetto fermi
forse ce l'ha forse il sangue la cavano
benone rossetto il lupo nero e rossetto
poteri sono rimasti pochissimi ma
allora la mia domanda questa volta è un
uomo o una donna
e un uomo skate però in effetti
pensandoci un uomo potrebbe voler dire
tante cose perché ad esempio fosse una
bambola o mostro non sarebbe anche se
fosse una donna non sarebbe un uomo
quindi io dico no non è un uomo perché
avresti dovuto fare la domanda meglio
impedire è un marchio o no ci hai
ragione quindi posso solo eliminare
quello nei borghi nonno il lupo non so
il lupo trappola lo possiamo eliminare
poi gioca virtus non lo so
ok
indossa una maglietta o un maglione
colorato non sono sicuro se una
maglietta in realtà avere un maglione no
neanche un po che
si indossa qualcosa di colorato allora
posso eliminare dracula e balistica fare
la domanda è per caso il broncio questo
personaggio si sa il bronzo quindi
dobbiamo eliminare tutti quelli che
sorridono a chi va chi sta sorridendo
chi si mi si sta sorridendo il kriens
sta sorridendo in isolamento che
rimangono solo 1 2 3 4 e un insegnante
si vince niente ok allora possiamo
togliere annabelle e mister mente e ci
rimangono
costituente niente
il colore degli occhi e celeste per caso
no non ha gli occhi se l'è quindi puoi
eliminare tutti quelli che gli
occhialetti ciechi
malefica ballo c'e la verdi l'ho visto
adesso anche neanche malefico annatelli
mi sembra abbiano gli occhi celesti
quindi meno sono rimasti ancora 5 o no
iphone e il come sono rimasti solo due
mesi lo provero vento fine il tuo
personaggio e banti silvia baldi e
quelli che invece il suo personaggio
almeno voglio sapere se ci sono andato
vicino il mio personaggio era molto
simile a baldini infatti avevo il dubbio
che magari avessimo scelto lo stesso
personaggio perché il mio personaggio
era scrive
no e voi avete indovinato passiamo ora
al prossimo turno è arrivato il momento
di scegliere il personaggio che
ho scelto anch'io ho scelto e rapido
l'ora di cominciare questa volta non
vincerai vedremo vedremo chi vincerà
questa volta non è il vostro personaggio
preferito tra tutti questi scrivetecelo
nei commenti se non avete ancora
lasciato mi piace è la stata è un mi
piace ora siccome prima iniziato tumore
inizi io con lui ai peli bene sentono
riferiti poi penso tu leffe
ma è venuto quindi ana peluria
allora o si ai peli quindi devo togliere
tutti quelli non per oggi
joker valdemort
baldi il gelataio
trappola allora devi scavare sbriga
noi non lo devo lasciare a chi internet
ma l'etica
questa domanda sono il super vantaggio
abbiamo solamente il lupo egregio i
servizi ai quali è breve ma il tuo
personaggio
ha per caso un accessorio tipo un
accessorio in testa come un cappello o
qualcosa in mano o degli occhiali no non
ha nessun accessorio allora a chi ha un
accessorio e lunedì borno grendi neanche
allora il lupo a un accessorio e non un
accessorio in bocca la chiave e virna ma
gli occhiali come accessorio freddi al
capello giocherà qualcosa in mano
abbiamo di meglio in realtà è ancora in
vantaggio la vita la mia domanda per
questo turno e agli occhi neri si sa gli
occhi neri di miglioramento in dominato
preti agli occhi chiari il crash anni
verdi il colore sono gli occhi del lupo
non riesco a capirlo di che colore sono
così come un lupo avrà gli occhi gialli
o
verticalmente
domanda semplicissima maschio o femmina
ma devo risponderti
massimo femmina
e un maschio no non è un maschio quindi
lynch lo slime air
sguardi fissi missino gelataio voldemort
baldi renderman dracula mister mi ero
nei voti almeno sono un pochettino più
avanti adesso io ho fatto una buona
domanda beh io minuto
allora qua abbiamo solo due colori blu e
rosa siccome è vitale team blu ea la
tabella blu e la maglietta sul secondo
me l'ua chi è
il tuo ragionamento non fa una piega e
vinto a dirlo ma
[Applauso]
[Musica]
allora allora mi sono rimaste sono
personaggi femminili quindi secondo me
era grandi quello che è certo tutto è
una cosa più di me e che il mio
personaggio era chi
non ci credo
certo aghi mag io ho scelto kiss ti
metti la fidanzata però sono riuscito a
dominare che mai
grazie alla domanda del pelo sono
riuscita subito ad arrivare ad hollywood
diciamo un turno di rivincita e vediamo
se questa volta riesce a vincere ai
sente il suo personaggio ricco scelto
anche allora la domanda il tuo
personaggio fa vedere i denti non può
vedere i gay dobbiamo eliminare g sermit
si vedono gli enti splendere in una
dracula in due sedi e in una mostra
sguardi sinisi del gioco ma la domanda
resta volta se in vantaggio quindi
rimettere la domanda divertente però
potrebbe essere pericoloso nel senso che
potrebbe eliminare o nessuno o quasi
tutti dai [ __ ] il tuo personaggio è
bello bella è una domanda un po
soggettiva qui potresti sbagliare
completamente con questa domanda durati
41 curiosa la risposta è di chi sarà poi
se lo trovi bello o bella secondo me è
un personaggio bello bello bello
ovviamente non può essere a chi va chi è
sicuramente la questione volte ma
nemmeno
giocherà nemmeno una bella da mary di
kerman vero che i sinistri nemmeno la
slimer nemmeno i greci nemmeno slider
man forse dracula può essere bello nei
feti e lo neighbor 9 di nota paranoid
rigano lei può essere bella il giorno no
il lupo può essere bello forse si sa chi
no mister mit no e malefica sicuramente
può essere bella perché bellizzi qual è
la tua domanda non ci posso credere
sviluppato in vantaggio aspetta però è
perché potresti avere sbagliato come ho
detto prima magari la bellezza è
soggettiva quindi quello che bello per
membri bello per terra certo mi vuoi
dire che magari tu voldemort e lo trovi
bello anzi bellissimo
i gusti sono gusti
quindi potresti aver sbagliato per tutto
non lo so non vedo l'ora di scoprire chi
sarà per vedere chi è che trovi bello
bene ma vediamo il tuo personaggio e
pelato e no non è pelato dobbiamo
eliminare baldi
vogliono il gelataio prendermi mondo
vorrei ancora farete le domande strane e
divertenti farò una domanda four ha mai
eliminato credo proprio di sì
qualcuno di molto pericoloso però anche
bello ma che ci fa cose
giuste ha eliminato qualcuno ed è pure
bello
dracula potrebbe essere anche materica
anche dopo che vestiva tutto hanno
eliminato qualcuno e aspetta maris che
eliminate qualcuno non lo so non ne sono
sicura guardi non mi sembra che abbia
mai eliminato nessuno no mi metto solo
il castigo e niente è andato un po male
questa domanda ha per caso capelli rossi
na non ha i capelli rossi e quindi
dobbiamo eliminare ciò che è lo nego e
aspetto però sui portato io adesso
provate il vostro zio ceriale una mia
domanda è è un personaggio dei
videogiochi
non credo ci sia un videogioco su questo
personaggio quindi no non fa parte dei
videogiochi allora possiamo eliminare il
gelataio
freddi rimangono
tuo personaggio è bionda yo akao biondo
scusa è bionda bionda ma così io ti
potrei dire no se fosse un maschio
biondo che avrei detto di no perché
chiesto serie bionda ma io ti ho detto
bionda termina il tuo personaggio
femmine bionda no non è bionda non è
bionda
quindi non è l'enpa ne sono rimasti solo
quattro siamo paesi luogo che portare
molto attenta alla mia domanda adesso a
questo personaggio si vedono i capelli
si si vedono i capelli possiamo
eliminare malefica e la moglie dice che
si vedono mai lupo si vedono i bigodini
e dracula si vedono quindi non rimangono
conviene stare attento con la sua
domanda
credo di aver capito il tuo personaggio
per caso odia il natale
come hai fatto a capirlo davvero mi odia
il natale quindi immagino che hai capito
allora ho capito chi è il tuo
personaggio è babbo natale
doveva portare tutti quei regali non
male gloria è schizzato sto scherzando
dabo natale non è horror e allora il tuo
personaggio è il grip
a me invece erano rimasti dracula il
lupo e la moglie di jackie e quindi
secondo te allora sono indecisa tra
draquila politi ciardi perché non penso
che trovi il lupo molto bello
mi sembra strano che trovi la moglie di
chucky bella quindi ma magari hai
sbagliato quando hai fatto quella
domanda secondo me tra pula noi
sbagliamo di nuovo e la voglia di chuck
infatti è la trovi bella è bella
è bella da emi che brutta sicuramente la
magnetica che è bella o brutta fa paura
ha concluso il terzo round ho vinto io
no 2 1 ma poi anche un altro episodio la
state ben mi piace a 10 mila mi piace
fare un altro indovinati e ora mi lascia
quattro fratellini su cui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video cade su
quella che preferite una visione sarà